[MUSIC]
Hello everyone, and
welcome to today's webcast,
MBA student insights and
military veterans at the GSB.
My name is Steve Barber I have just
finished my MBA one year here at
Stanford I'm joined today by
my fellow veteran classmates,
Sarah Martin and Vaneet Rajan.
We'll be talking about the student
experience at the GSB today and
the experience on campus as well.
And we'll try to get to as many
questions of yours as we can.
If any questions come
up during the webinar,
please feel free to use the Q&A box
at the bottom of your screen and
towards the end of the webcast we'll
answer how ever many we have time for.
We're not going to talk too much about he
admission process today so if you have any
questions on that you can always consult
the website as well as use the Q&A box and
our admission staff will try to
answer as many of those as they can.
So we'll kick it off with some
introductions we'll start with Sarah,
Sarah aan you tell us a little bit about
your background, where you're from,
what you did in the military,
why you came to the GSB, and
essentially what you're looking
to do after you finish?
>> Sure, Steve.
>> Thanks.
>> So I'm from the Bay Area Area, so
right around Stanford.
I went to West Point, the US
military academy, graduated in 2009.
And I worked as a logistics officer and
also in foreign language education.
And after the GSB, I'm going to go back to
the Army and I will teach at West Point.
And as far as why I came to the GSB, it's
a top notch program and I was particularly
interested in entrepreneurship and
it has a very strong program for that.
>> Thanks, Sarah.
How about you, Vaneet?
>> Sure.
So, I'm Vaneet Rajan.
I grew up in Maryland and
joined the Marines as an intel officer for
the last 11 years.
Left the UK,
where it was my last duty station, and
came to the GSB with my wife Sundria and
our two children.
And what I hope to do after the business
school is go into entrepreneurship or
impact investing.
>> Outstanding, and
as I said in the intro, I'm Steve Barber.
I was in the US Navy for
11 years as F18 pilot.
I came to the GSB also knowing that it was
a top notch program and hoping to take my
experience in aerospace as a pilot and
transition it over to the business world.
I married as well, I met my husband Jimmy
in the Navy and I grew up in San Diego.
Okay let's hit the questions,
the good part.
So we'll start out with some of
the questions we've gotten received in
advance.
So we'll start with how
was the transition from
being in the military to being in school?
So for me I'd say there are aspects that
I thought went a little
easier than I anticipated.
There are aspects that are a little
bit harder than I thought.
So what was easier was getting
back into the academic mindset.
I think you can be confident
that if the GSB selects you for
admission, you have what it takes
to really thrive and excel here.
And it took a few weeks to remember
how to study, how to take notes, and
what exams feel like, but relatively
quickly I got back up on plane there and
remembered how to be a student.
And there's so many resources here at
the GSB to help you get to that point that
that process was much
smoother than I anticipated.
Takes some people a little
longer than others but for
me it was relatively smooth and
I was lucky.
Something that was harder than I
anticipated transitioning from
the military to business school is and
you'll hear this many times and the
context of business schools anywhere is
this idea of FOMA a fear of missing out.
There is so much that goes on at
Stanford that I really found that,
when I was in the military,
we had a mission in mind and I knew
what I was doing for most of the week.
We had goals we were
going to try to achieve, and
that really defined a lot of my actions.
My social circle was pretty well defined
based on the people that I knew in
the military, and it kind of added
some structure to life that I
found is a little less prominent here.
Again, there's so much that's
going on with extra curriculars
you can be involved in, career research
and tracks and just the millions of
offerings that the GSB has that it was
tough at first for me to prioritize and
budget my time to know what
was important to me and what I
really wanted to spend the most of my time
doing and getting out of this experience.
Everyone that I've talked to has struggled
with this in some way, shape or form.
So it's very natural.
But it wasn't something that I could
fully appreciate until I came here.
And while it's been tough at times, it's
also a really tremendous strength at this
school, that there really are just
all these avenues to explore and
develop yourself and
answer questions about who you are and
what you want to do after
you finish up the GSB.
Another question we had was about what
we're studying or specializing in.
The GSB might be a little bit different
from some of the other schools out there
as far as how we study and
specialize in our degree.
Sarah, can you talk a little
bit about that for us?
>> Sure.
So we have a general MBA program.
And so the first year,
everyone takes most of the same classes.
And there is some opportunity
to take electives.
And with the general foundations,
you can take classes at different levels.
And that was something that actually
really appealed to me about
the Stanford program was that I can take
the same classes as everyone else but
at a level that was appropriate to me.
So, if I wanted to take advanced
operations, I could do that.
But if I wanted to take basic finance
because I didn't have a finance
background, that made a lot of sense.
I do, I have had room to take some
electives during my first year.
For example, I'm personally really
interested in healthcare and so
I was able to take two
healthcare classes including
the biodesign innovation course which
is an nice flagship program and
I did a global study trip
that was healthcare focused.
>> Awesome, very cool.
How do you feel Nat?
What are your thoughts on that question
about the way our curriculum's
designed and how we study here?
>> I think, like Sarah said, the appeal
to me coming to the GSB was the fact that
there was a general management foundation
that I wanted and could achieve here.
But at the same time, it wasn't so
prescriptive that I couldn't take some of
the classes that I wanted to,
particularly in the winter or the spring.
I also did appreciate,
much like to Sarah's point,
that I could take a class that was right
for my capabilities so I had a little bit
of finance background so I could take
a little more advanced finance classes but
I could go into more basic classes for
data and decisions, for example.
>> That's a great point.
And I was definitely the base classes for
everything that I took here and,
like you said, I really appreciated,
kind of, being able to
dip my toe in these new subjects without
feeling overwhelmed because there's so
many people with diverse backgrounds
here that If I was thrown in with all
say finance majors or
people who had worked in say finance or
investment banking I probably
would have been over my head.
Stanford gets that not everyone comes
at the same place when they get here.
And really tailors the curriculum to,
I find,
give everyone a great chance to succeed.
>> Absolutely.
>> Thanks, guys.
All right.
We hit little bit on this when we kind
of did our intros, but can you speak in
a little more depth, Vaneet,
about what made you decide to apply and
ultimately attend Stanford as opposed to
some of the other schools you looked at?
>> Absolutely, so one of the biggest draws
for me was the fact that, like I said,
the General Management Foundation
is I think really important for
those of us who are transitioning
out of the military service.
So I did 11 years in the Marine Corps,
and I knew that I needed to
relearn some of the accounting and
finance that I learned 11 years ago.
So that was a big draw for me, but I also
was really appreciative of the fact that
it wasn't so prescriptive and that I
had some flexibility in my first year.
And some of the schools,
other schools I was looking at
didn't have that flexibility.
I really wanted that.
The number two reason why I came here was
that much like Sarah, I'm very interested
in entrepreneurship and
especially a focus on social innovation.
And the GSB is really known for
those two things in particular so
that was a huge draw for me.
And then, I didn't want to leave the
Marine Corps and then come to a school and
get lost in the huge class size.
And so I found that the GSB class size
what it's about the right level for
me where I can hopefully meet
everybody in my class and
actually know their names and develop
a relationship with them, but not be so
small that the network wouldn't be useful
for me Decades after I graduate, and
the last thing,
because I came from the UK as my last
I really wanted something with good
weather, if I'm being totally honest.
My children like to be outside, and
it's really helpful that the weather
is beautiful almost all the year here.
>> That's definitely
an important consideration.
Thank you.
So we brought up entrepreneurship.
You just spoke to it there, Vineet.
We've had questions about whether vets
can go the entrepreneurial route.
So, I guess, starting with you,
Sarah, I think you've had some
experience in this avenue.
Can you talk to how it's been for you,
kind of pursuing entrepreneurial ventures,
as a first year student,
and looking forward?
>> Sure, I think actually veterans
fall pretty naturally into
an entrepreneurial route.
They've worked in large organizations.
They can see the limitations of that and
how sort of disruptive alternative ideas
can really accomplish a lot, and so
there's veterans in all sorts of programs.
I'm in the biodesign innovation program,
and I've been working on a medical
device that my team has invented, and
we are planning to work on it this summer.
So I'm just one example of someone
who's gone into innovative space.
We have a classmate, Patrick Robinson,
who's working on another startup
involving computer vision,
and I guess,
how would you phrase what he does?
>> I think he's using technology to
help the criminal justice system be
able to not hold people too
accountable for certain things.
But there's a lot of opportunities here
for entrepreneurship, whether you're
a veteran or not, and I think the problem
for the veterans will be is the fact that
you have not had the opportunity to really
think about being entrepreneurial in
the traditional sense while in
the military, but now you're dropped into
this huge place of resources where
there's so many classes, so many clubs.
And almost more importantly, there's a lot
of people who are also interested in
entrepreneurship, so
it doesn't end in the classroom.
You often take it outside
of the classroom and
spend a lot of time with your colleagues
working on personal endeavors.
So I think veterans are very suited for
entrepreneurship,
it's just whether you're interested in it,
and then whether you want to take
a chance while here at the GSB.
>> For sure, and then just worth noting,
you mentioned Patrick, Sarah.
He's also a veteran in our class, and
our class mate, so rough numbers,
at least 25% of our veterans,
just in our class,
are doing something entrepreneurial over
there for summer and possibly beyond.
So it gives you a pereety good sense
of the resources that are here for
people who maybe don't have formal
experience in the space, but
have the drive and the hustle to really
do something kind of world changing, and
something I really value about being here.
>> And that's what really stands out about
veterans, is the drive and the hustle, so
if you have an idea,
the resources here are so plentiful.
So you can be in venture studios, you can
take lead launch pads, start-up garage,
biodesign innovation class,
classes of design school.
So it's sort of like limitless
opportunities if you've got idea and
drive, which a lot of veterans do have.
>> Totally, and it’s not always just if
you have an idea for a product or company,
let's just say there’s other avenues for
entrepreneurial endeavors,
like search funds for example, which are
something that veterans also do a lot of
that we sort of pioneered the model four
at Stanford, have a ton of resources to
support those, and
that again veterans are ideally suited for
in a lot of circumstances, just because
they're used to kind of rotating into
a new job every year or so, and learning
it quickly and really excelling at it.
So, I'm glad we had this kind of
discussion on the details of the stuff
that's not there,
because it's not just I come to Stanford
because I want launch a company.
There's so
many ways to be entrepreneurial here, all
of which are incredibly all supportive.
>> Absolutely.
>> So, it's something I value as well.
Another question that's come in, so
the vets club is obviously
a huge source of support for us.
We can talk on terms to military members,
and share our experiences,
and get things that maybe the perspective
of our classmates that they haven't
been exposed to,
so we can kind of build community in that
way, but there's so many other clubs here.
We talked, both of you have alluded to the
entrepreneurship and tech facing clubs.
But there's other professional
organizations and clubs that Stanford
offers that can help people in their
career search, or just to find community.
So can both of you maybe offer your
perspective on some of the clubs that have
been meaningful to you
in your GSB experience?
>> Sure, you start.
>> Sure, so I'm one of the co-presidents
for the Social Innovation Club.
As I mentioned that I came here to
the GSB particularly because I wanted to
research that interest of mine, of social
innovation and social entrepreneurship,
and so Social Innovation Club has
taken a huge part of my time,
but that's because I really am
interested in that space, and so
one of the other clubs I'm really
interested is the Venture Capital Club.
And so because I'm doing venture capital
position this summer the resources that I
had, not only with just having the brown
bag lunches with current venture
capitalist, but also talking to my
peers who had experience in the venture
capital industry,
has been really helpful for me to grow and
potentially launch a career after the GSB.
>> Cool, how about you Sarah?
>> Awesome, so I'm in the Healthcare Club,
and that's been really good.
For example,
just a couple of weeks ago we did this
awesome track through Silicone Valley.
We visited a couple of different
startups in Biotech, and also and
it was really good just to have that first
hand experience touring their companies,
getting to talk to the CEOs,
the startups, and
then other folks in was really awesome.
It's also really helpful for job postings.
So, the different clubs will often
share internship opportunities and
connections within that industry.
The Healthcare Club's definitely
been really great for that.
I'm also co-leading
the Adam Smith Society, which is basically
a club where we debate free market
solutions to different problems,
whether it's social security,
or healthcare, or pros and
cons of globalization, and
that's just kind of a fun club to think,
kind of like take a step out of your
everyday life here at the GSB and
think about these much larger issues,-
>> Sure.
>> And so that's been really
fun to think about that, and
be involved with some
of those discussions.
It's also tied into the Hoover Institute
quite a bit, and so
we get some really great speakers.
>> That's really cool.
I know stuff that I've done.
I'm involved with GSB Pride, which is our
LGBT community organization here on campus
that's been a great source of support
in meeting a lot of great new friends.
I'm also involved with,
this isn't technically an extracurricular,
but one of the kind of flagship programs
that the GSB offers is called
the Arbuckle Fellows Program.
And what that is, is in your second year
you have the opportunities as an MBA2,
to lead what's called a squad of
six MBA1s, first-year students, and
together in that squad,
in this very small intimate venue,
you work through case studies, and
role plays, and discussions, and
reflections to really find out what kind
of leader you want to be, and as the MBA2,
you are essentially
owning that discussion.
You are helping your squad members
discover what it is that they maybe
didn't know about themselves,
helping them finding strengths that they
didn't know they had, helping them work
on weakness that they are aware of, and
I know my experience as an MBA1 in squad
was tremendously rewarding, and I'm so
lucky that now I get the chance
to carry that forward and
help kind of shape just a little piece of
the leadership development that MBAs get
over their two years at the GSB.
>> That's very cool.
>> So, it's something I'm really,
really looking forward to.
>> How many Arbuckle Fellows are there?
>> I think there are about 70 or
so Arbuckle Fellows.
It's a competitive program.
You'll typically apply, just in
the beginning of your second quarter here,
in the winter quarter, and you'll
interview, you have essays to write, and
then ultimately they'll select,
and if you are picked up for it,
there's an extensive training
that you go through.
You take one of Stanford's signature
classes called Touchy Feely.
There's a lot of information
out there on that.
I took it this quarter, it was amazing.
And then, when you're serving as
in Arbuckle fellow, it's not just
the meetings with the squad mates,
you're also having the chance to take two
full quarters worth of classes where you
talk about what's going on your squad.
You have a one-on-one coaching session
multiple times per the quarter.
And you really dissect it
down to what techniques can I
use that make me effective as a leader,
and what techniques can I
explore in a safe space that really might
be more effective for me as I go forward,
and kind of try and find what's a good
fit for me in the civilian world.
>> That's awesome.
>> Yeah, I'm really,
really looking forward to it.
A question that's come in about a little
more on the nose for military stuff is,
do GSB students tend to
serve in the Reserves?
Can any of you comment on
sort of the reserve mix, and
if you were able to incorporate
that into your GSB experience?
>> Sure, I really thought
about joining the Reserves or
actively participating in the Reserves
when I left the Marines about a year ago.
I think it's a very personal decision.
Like I said, I have a family and
my decision making process went around
what I really wanted out of the Reserves,
and what the cost and
benefits of that experience would be.
And for me,
it just seemed like the opportunity cost
to participate on the reserve at least
at this time, would be too high for
my family and for
my academic experience here.
Though, I will say that
there's a small minority of
the veteran population here that is
actively participating in Reserves.
And there's plenty of opportunities to
do that, if that makes sense for you.
So don't be worried about
coming to the GSB and
saying you won't be able to
participate in your service, you can.
There's plenty of
opportunities to do that.
The question is, does that make sense for
you in your current situation while you
are here at the GSB for those two years.
I may very well actively participate
in the reserve when I graduate.
>> That's a great point, and I think
a lot people find that they maybe start
in the Reserves and over the initial
time at the GSB, discover that it's
not something that is compatible with
what their priorities are at that point.
And that's the beauty of
the Reserves in my view,
is that you can always
transition out of act of duty.
Start with the Reserves,
and if it's not working at that point
in your life you can transition out.
Maybe look to join back up later on if
that's something that appeals to you.
And I know that's been the case with
some of our fellow veteran community
members here at the GSB.
>> One thing I'd want to add there Steve,
is the fact that as you transition just
make sure that, if this is appropriate for
you, you apply for
your reserve commission.
So that you have it,
should you want to go ahead and
pursue that during your time at the GSB.
So make sure you do
the paperwork beforehand, so
you don't close that door unnecessarily.
>> Absolutely, it's much easier to leave
the second time than it is to try to get
back in after fully closing the door,
as you say.
>> Right.
>> And
I don't think we have any in our class who
are actively in the Reserves right now,
at least veteran members.
But I know in classes before,
people from all
branches of the military have found units
around here that allow them to drill, and
that was our GSB obligations
with their military service.
So it can be done.
It's a very personal decision that you
really just going to have to think long
and hard about.
We talked about the Reserves, Sarah
you're on active duty how has it been for
you on active duty balancing kind of
this civilian educational experience,
with the fact that you know
you're going back to active duty.
What do you think you'll take back to
active duty I think is a good question.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah,
I think that kind of ties back
to why I came to Stanford.
One of the reasons I came to
Stanford was for the ideas.
Stanford and the Silicon Valley,
there's such a different way of thinking
that's sort of related to tech and
entrepreneurship.
And I wanted to be exposed to those ideas,
and take it back to the RMA.
>> Okay.
>> Getting back to the first
part of your question,
what is it like being here on active duty?
I think some parts of the experience
are a little bit different for me,
is that I don't have to,
I feel like I have more freedom.
I know everyone was really thinking
about their summer internships,
like this is going to make or break it for
my career, it's really super important.
I know exactly where I'm going after the
GSB, so I think it took a lot of pressure
off of me to just focus on
areas I wanted to explore.
And so I've got to do these,
I'm doing an internship in
Paris in finance later on this summer, and
I'm also working on this med tech company.
[LAUGH]
>> So,
it's been good to just sort
of explore the space, and
that's something that I think I
have as an active duty officer,
versus other people who are more
concerned about their post GSB work.
>> It's pretty cool that you get to take
advantage of not just knowing that you
will return to active duty and hopefully
bring these ideas to transform the army,
but that you have the space to
take advantage of all that the GSB
offers in your two years here.
I know all our other active duty veterans
who are here at least in our class right
now, have found a lot of the same success
that you have in that department.
>> Absolutely.
>> So, that's awesome.
We're going to move on now to the audience
questions that have been submitted,
we'll get to as many of them as we can.
First one, let's see.
This is a great one, so two of you
mentioned that you had served for
ten plus years one married with kids.
Do you find yourself challenged in any
different way by being a little older than
the average student, or have any
general advice for someone applying for
someone that is a little more removed
from their college experience?
>> Okay, I'll jump on this grenade.
>> You win.
>> So, I would say that one, we have a
over-30 group here, which is very select.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You have to be over 30 years old
to be part of this.
>> It's one of the more
elite groups on campus.
>> Elite group at the GSB.
And it is heavily influenced by veterans.
In all seriousness, I think that
having a family definitely affects
my perspective, and how I look at the GSB,
and what I'm going to do here.
I've got two kids under the age of five,
and so
tea time with my daughter, or
wrestling with her, or my son and
taking them outside to play,
is a big priority for me.
And that means that I give up
other things, like networking on
certain occasions or
social event that might be going on.
So, I think being older and
having kids does affect the way you
look at the GSB experience, but it's not
forced upon you, it's a decision and
a priority that I've made for my family.
Being older also gives me
the added advantage of
just being able to see things
with a different perspective.
Right?
And that doesn't come with age
necessarily, but it does come typically
with being in the military for ten years.
I think that has been an advantage.
The thing that may be a little
bit of a disadvantage,
if I'm being totally honest is,
maybe your experienced is differ but
working in the government means that
there's a lot more bureaucracy and
a lot more older technologies
that I have to use.
And coming to the GSB where everybody's
really super tech savvy, means that you
might have to like pick up to tech game,
on how to collaborate with other people
and how to excel to it's full capacities
as an example, or even PowerPoint.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
none of those obstacles
are insurmountable.
But there were some differences that I
experienced when I first got to the GSB.
>> Yeah, I really second that.
So I'm from the Silicon Valley.
So I thought,
like the tech thing'll be easy.
And coming here there was all these
different modes of communication,
whether it was like Trello,
WhatsApp, GroupMe.
Slack, I was like, what's Slack?
And so it took some getting used to,
but we had tons of classmates that
are super helpful, really kind and
understand the stuff.
So if you're a vet my advice would be,
just sit down with one of your classmates,
and they'll kind of walk you through it.
To answer this question first, one of the
strengths I think a lot of veterans have
is that we've been in situations before,
where you're just kind of like thrown and
it's sort of this baptism by fire.
You figure it out.
And so we figure it out,
and we persevere, and
it was a bit rough navigating all
of the jargon the first quarter.
Actually, if I have my one piece of fun
advice, that I'm actually very serious
about, is to watch to show
the Silicon Valley, have you seen it?
>> Yeah.
>> It's the greatest, [LAUGH]
>> So as soon as I watched that show,
everything made sense to me.
I was like.
Yeah.
Cap tables, term sheets,
SAS, the whole thing B2B,
it was all just jargon before but
now I've got it all down.
>> Clearly you're ready for
that internship in finance.
>> Yeah.
>> One thing I will say,
just to add to that,
if you've been in the service for
a decade or longer, you probably will
have been, if you're an officer or major,
or close to being a major,
you gotta hang that
at the door when you come to the GSB and
just get in the mix with everybody else.
If you hold on to your past so
much in what rank you used to have, it
might be an impediment for you to be able
to really get the most out as experience.
Albeit that some of your classmates
might be 24, 25 but they're here for
a reason, and
they've got a lot of value to add.
So sit alongside them and they'll be
teaching you something in the evening and
it would be a sad day if you left
this business school without having
rubbed some elbows with some 24 year
olds who really know what they're doing.
>> Absolutely.
>> Awesome thank you, guys.
Here's a question that came in,
after the GI bill on
yellow ribbon program assistance, what
would be the estimated financial burden?
So I can address this one.
There's a lot of depths of complexity to
this one, so baseline assumptions going in
I'm at at 100% eligibility for
the Yellow Ribbon Program and GI Bill.
If you don't know what that means, make
sure to take a look at the VA's website.
It can be a little complicated,
and if there are more
questions we can help you out.
But if you're at 100% eligibility as I am
and didn't receive any sort of outside
financial aid or fellowships, the level
of assistance offered is the same for
everybody at Stanford, if they're at
100% eligibility for the GI bill.
What that entails is, for
the 2018 academic year,
roughly 23k from the government.
With Yellow Ribbon funds the way they are,
that's roughly another 39K on top of that.
So right now you're looking at, I'm always
terrified of math in public, but over
$60,000 that will be furnished to everyone
who is at 100% Yellow Ribbon eligibility.
And with tuition last year in
the neighborhood of high 60s to low 70s,
it's a significant chunk
covered by Stanford for
people at full Yellow Ribbon eligibility.
So very, very helpful for
veterans that have served for a long time.
And then remember, on top of that,
that there's also the housing
allowance that's paid to you.
Every month that appears on the order
of 3,600 a month that's fixed to
cost of living for the area.
So that's a huge benefit, especially
if you live out in town like me.
And there's also a tuition textbook
stipend that's paid every year as well,
it's about $1,000.
So bottom line, a significant amount of
financial aid is available to those who
are at 100% Yellow Ribbon eligibility.
And even for those who aren't, there
are tons of options that the GI bell, or
the GSB financial aid office can educate
you on that might be workable for you.
There's standard federal loans, there's
private loans, there's another GI or
a VA program called Vocational Rehab
that I'm not super smart on.
But the bottom line is there are a ton
of options out there for financial aid.
And if you really want to
come to Stanford,
I would say that try to make that be just
one part of the overall calculation.
And it may have some more weight for
some as it does for others.
But only you know that so just give it
the due consideration that it deserves,
regardless if you're at full eligibility,
I can tell you that the GI bill is very,
very helpful, attending Stanford
certainly has helped me.
>> I just add one more thing as well.
As you consider what schools you want to
go to, once you get accepted to the many
schools you probably want to apply to,
take an apples to apples comparison.
And actually compare what you would get if
you were to go to another school
because I was actually shocked as I
did the comparison myself as we
transitioned as a family to the GSB,
that the GSB after all the support
provided me was actually much more
affordable than some other schools
that I expected to be more affordable.
So it actually worked out to
be economically a line for
me to come to the GSB, and
that was to my surprise.
So just do the analysis,
practice your pre MBA skills,
make an Excel sheet, and
adjust for the cost of living, and
you might be surprised that coming to
the GSB is actually the best place to go.
>> Awesome.
Got time for just a couple more questions
if we keep our answers pretty quick.
So we'll just try to get to them here.
Looking back, following your first year,
what would you recommend potential
students do to best prepare themselves
prior to returning to school?
I've got two one-sentence answers.
The first one would be try
to relax a little bit.
You'll definitely,
if you've been picked to come here,
you have the skills to succeed.
So no need to super overload if you don't
want to if you feel comfortable kind of
doing some prep on like Excel or
something like that, you can do that.
I would say you don't need to and then
my other quick sentence advice would be
look at the possibility and see if it's
right for you to do a pre MBA internship.
There are a lot of big companies and
tech and finance and
consulting that offer veteran specific
opportunities to work in finance or
work in consulting for a summer,
just to get a taste of it.
And that's essentially a free internship
where you can either set yourself up to
go back to that field if you really
like it and your first MBA 1 internship.
Or if you don't like it, you've learned a
lot and you have an educated perspective,
eyes open,
about what it means to work there.
So that's kind of my advice that I
would give myself, looking back on it.
What do you all think?
>> So I'll just reiterate my first
piece of advice which is watch the show
Silicon Valley.
because everything will make sense.
>> Excellent, underline.
>> [LAUGH].
And, I totally second you on the Excel.
If you have a chance, and you want to
take some of the more accelerated or
the advanced classes when you get on to
campus, I would encourage students or
admits to take a look at the study
materials that they give you.
And try to brush up on some of these
subjects, especially if you want to place
into some of these accelerator,
or higher level classes.
That being said,
if you don't have the time,
don't stress out about it
because you'll be fine.
I didn't.
I was really busy leading
up to coming here so
I didn't have the time to work on
any of that stuff and I was fine.
So just do whatever makes sense for you.
>> Cool.
>> Really quickly,
I would say that you won't have a ton of
time here to do some deep level thinking
about what you want your life to look like
after the GSB, which is a bit surprising.
So I would say if you've got the time and
the bandwidth,
I would definitely just sit down and
talk to your significant other or
your friends and like kind of design
your way through what you want
your life to look like outside of the GSB
so you can hit the ground running.
Even with the academic adjustment period
being what it is here, recruiting
starts pretty quickly and you won't have
the time to really think about it, so
if you can think about it before you
come to the GSB, it'd be very helpful.
>> And then, I think, maybe,
we have time for one or two more.
We've got the high sign.
Perfect.
All right, did you guys come to Stanford
GSB knowing exactly what field you wanted
to specialize in, and how's your
perpsective changed since your time here?
Do you want to start us out on that?
>> Sure, I did not know.
I said that piece of advice because I
didn't have the time to think about what I
wanted.
And so, my perspective has certainly
changed partially because I know a lot
more about what private equity looks like
now, and what investment banking is.
I didn't know what any of those things
were really before I came here, and
I realized some of those things
aren't just for me and my family.
And so I think as you learn more about
each of these possibilities, you'll make
the right decision based on your desires
and what you're really capable of doing.
GSB opens a lot of doors, but there
are some things that you're just not going
to be able to do because you spent
11 years or 10 years in the service,
as compared to your colleagues who did
investment banking right out of undergrad.
>> Absolutely, yeah I would say that
veterans were all by the nature of our
transition, we're transitioning
from one career field to another.
So I think there's very much the
expectation that you don't know what you
want to do.
It's very common.
I think it's definitely really
a good idea to have priorities or
areas of interest before you come here so
you don't lose focus.
But you'll figure it out
as you get exposed to sort
of the smorgasbord of
different opportunities.
That's an excellent word, that's
an MBA word right there, [INAUDIBLE].
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
I guess I also didn't know
exactly what I wanted to do.
I was pretty focused in where I thought
I wanted to end up in aerospace,
which is related to my background.
That's I'd say probably not
in my experience most veterans end up
doing something completely different than
what they did in the military when they
leave and go to the business world.
I'm kind of tangentially
staying in the same way.
So I knew where I wanted to end up, but
as far as function, I had no idea and
frankly still don't.
I had the opportunity to
do a pre-MBA internship for
an aircraft leasing company that I'll
be returning to for half the summer.
And then I'll also be working for
an aerospace startup as well for
the second half of my summer.
So I'm exploring different functions
within one broader industry.
And the GSB, far and away,
I would not have had the chance to
explore either of these internships,
both of which are really exciting,
without the resources and the benefits
of being here in this program.
So yeah, I didn't know what I wanted to
specialize in either and I still don't.
Hopefully we'll figure
it out over the summer.
But if you don't, it's totally cool,
because a lot of people have
that exact same experience.
And there's a chance to reinvent yourself
ten different times at the GSP if you want
to and if you need to.
So certainly nothing to be afraid of.
What, this may be our last one.
How about this?
How do you think your military experience
helps strengthen your application?
And what other extracurricular
activities did you have that
you believe maybe were an asset
to you as you applied?
I'll start on that one.
I think our military experience, for me,
it gave me a lot of, really, unique and
interesting stories that helped show
ways in which I was able to demonstrate
leadership in my work in the Navy.
And that is such a central focus here
at the GSB, that I think your average
military veteran often has a huge
bank of those stories to draw on.
And I think that can really strengthen
your application, make it more powerful,
make it about you and
show the various talents you have.
So just the kind of unique experience
that as a military member you
get that most other people
don't get was huge for me, and
I think was an asset to my application.
How about you, Sara?
>> Yeah, I would definitely
second the leadership component.
I had the opportunity to work in two
very different areas in the Army.
I led combat missions in Afghanistan.
And I also worked at the Defense
Language Institute where I led education
initiatives, really a flagship school for
foreign language education.
The types of leadership you need in
both scenarios are so different.
And I think that the military offers
you a lot of opportunities to explore
your leadership style to figure out how
to motivate different groups of people.
And we have exposure to
lots of different people.
So the military is kind of this
great geographic representation of
the United States, and
at least in the US military.
And we have kind of this global
outward thinking approach.
And I think those elements really
come out in veteran applications.
>> All right, we're almost out of time.
So before we head off, Sara and Venit,
do you have any final words of advice for
anyone out there who's
thinking about applying for
a Stanford MBA, especially if
they've served in the military?
We'll start with Sara.
>> I would say absolutely do it.
You can't catch a fish if
your hook's not in the water.
So try.
I think, one of the things I love to
highlight is the Veterans Club and
the veterans community here.
I think we're small but mighty.
We have a good representation of the
different services and also international
vets as well, especially we have some
from Korea and from Israel, especially.
So definitely apply.
And what was the first
part of your question?
>> That was basically it.
So final words of advice,
if you're applying for a Stanford MBA,
especially if you served in the military.
>> Yeah.
>> Awesome.
>> Apply.
>> I would second Sarah's thought.
I only applied quite frankly
because my wife convinced me to.
GSB was my number one choice,
but I thought I'd never
get into the school here.
And I applied very late,
at the part of the first season and
I'm here now, I'm very grateful for that.
And the other thing I would say as a
recommendation is really hone your story.
GSB is really about stories, and if you
don't have your story really tight about
what makes you special and different,
it's going to be hard to get in here.
>> Totally agree on that point, and for
me my piece of advice on honing
your story is to start early.
Ideally, you'll take plenty of time
to really craft those essays in
particular to give the most authentic
picture of you that you can.
And don't write the essays
thinking that you have to appear
as this incredibly super-hero type person.
Be authentic and be you and show what
you've truly done through your stories and
your experiences that makes
you differentiated and unique.
And if you focus more on just being true
to yourself and let that come through,
I think you'll find great success and
hopefully find yourself
among the next year's crop of applicants
or whenever you come to the GSB.
All right, thank you so
much to Sarah and Venit.
If you'd like, there are a tremendous
amount of resources and
points of contact available for
you on the GSB Veterans Club website.
Just Google that, it'll come right up.
There is also a contact form out
there if you'd like to try and
get in touch with any member
of the Veterans Club.
We're here as a resource to help you, and
if we don't know the answer
to a particular question,
we can definitely put you in touch
with someone who does know the answer.
So with that we'd like to say,
thanks so much for joining us today.
It's our absolute pleasure
to speak with you.
Good luck, and
we hope to see you all soon.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
[MUSIC]